yeah I really wanted to open with a joke
about putting this story in the freezer
I don't think enough people are gonna
get it though but if you did get it that
that joke killed hey everybody so I'm
calling this Oscar contender review
that's guess a mild misnomer because it
implies that I'm gonna see all the other
like major Oscar contenders before they
happen that I'm not doing that but I did
happen to see with Liz little women and
I want to talk about it because a it's
still playing in theaters in a fair a
number of places and B it's really
really good
the I'm taking the fact that it's an
Oscar contender as my excuse for putting
this on the main channel because
otherwise this might have shown up in
the break room
but it's up for Best Picture and I would
actually say deservedly so this is a
really good movie as far as my own
relationship with little women goes I've
never read the book I know the story
I've seen the 90s version the one with
Winona Ryder I feel like I've seen bits
and pieces of another version at some
point but I know the story basically
more or less but it's not like something
I grew up on and grow up reading it or
anything like that Liz did I really wish
I could have her on for this review but
uh it just the the timing and scheduling
didn't didn't work out unfortunately but
she did grow up in that book she read it
repeatedly she grew up on the 90s
version and she loved it as well and
boy it's hard to sell this if you don't
feel inclined to watch a period movie
about four sisters and honestly I'm
usually not inclined to watch that but
dang it this was good I mean first of
all it's worth pointing out the reason
Little Women is a classic and a classic
that's still read as opposed to an
academic classic an important book that
people talk about but nobody actually
reads for fun people still read a little
women for fun be and it's because it
speaks to a truth about growing up and
about sisterhood and about relationships
and about family dynamics in a way that
still holds true now and the movie
captures that really well and the cast
is phenomenal the the ones who have
Oscar nominations are sorcerer Ronin as
Joe of course because like it's not it's
not even worth asking who anyone's
favorite of the sisters and Little Women
is because everyone everyone says Joe
like right nobody nobody says something
other than Joe and the other one with
the nomination is Florence Pugh who
plays Amy which is interesting because I
do think there's at least a chunk of the
fandom of this book who if you were to
ask them their least favorite of the
sisters there's a decent shot a fair
number of them would say Amy so that's
kind of interesting there's some Amy is
a character who benefits from how this
actually has been reconfigured a bit
because the book just goes
chronologically from when the girls are
young all the way through to later in
life and when there's getting to an age
where they're getting married maybe some
of them have kids but the movie actually
jumps back and forth
between when they're young and later
years at a number of intervals it
actually flips back and forth fairly
regularly in a way that I actually think
is brilliant because it is taking
advantage of the medium of film because
this sort of jumping back and forth
wouldn't have flowed as well if the book
was like this because what cues you into
the changes are visual cues the the
scene set further in the girls history
are lit more warmly the ones further
down the timeline are lit more coldly
there are other visual signifiers like
say the length of Joe's hair and there
are things like that that make it so it
never has to stop and explain to you hey
we've moved back in time again you just
get the visual signifiers and it
wouldn't have flowed it nearly as well
in a book but by doing that without
altering the plots or the character
progression and actually being pretty
dang true to the book in terms of the
events it makes it feel different and
very fresh and of course for me that I'm
saying that relative is the nineties
movie but again speaking a little bit
for my partner Liz affirm the same thing
as someone who knows the book really
well it makes it feel it's a really neat
kind of magic trick because it makes it
feel fresh and new without actually
changing the substance of like any of it
that's a neat trick and I wouldn't I
feel like a lot of this was done to
create sort of thematic rhyming of
scenes to have to be able to complement
and show very close together if not
back-to-back scenes of events when they
are younger that and then some
complementary scenes from when they're
older that relate in some way to show
how things have stayed the same how
things have changed
and to pair those things off and I've
heard some people concerned that it was
confusing and if someone did find it
confusing I'm not gonna say you're wrong
but I didn't find it confusing I thought
it was brilliant I thought it was
amazing the the way that the temporal
trickery of it and to have it flow as
naturally and make again for me at least
absolute sense at every step of the way
man that's a trick to pull and Amy is a
character who I think benefits a lot
from that because in the book if you
don't know the story Amy is kind of
awful as a little kid she is spoiled she
she engages in temper tantrums and she
does some really hurtful stuff um when
she's young so when you read the book or
when you see any other adaptation that's
just going straight chronological what
that means is you see her at her worst
early on and for quite a chunk of time
and then you're expected to kind of
sympathize with her later and it's not
impossible but it's tricky whereas with
this you actually get to know her better
as I kind of pulled together adults
and then you learn about her backstory
and go oh she was just kind of a little
demon when she was a kid oh okay and it
fills out the back end as opposed to
being how you get to know her in the
first place and as a result I think she
just works really well I get why the
wife what if you was nominated and
there's uh there's also an addition of
kind of a speech that she has to the
character of Lori that is not lifted
directly from the book some of the
dialogue is but this this was an insert
sort of speech but again sort of
defaulting to Liz
she was very quick to point out no it's
still in character it's not a sort of
everything about this character now
pulls together and makes sense
speech it does not appear in the book
but it is a gathering of all the
elements of the character that are in
the book so even though it's granting
her basically sort of a statement of
purpose monologue and creating it out of
whole cloth
it's just reaffirming what character are
always was as opposed to rewriting it
there's also a very neat meta trick that
happens at the end in regard
specifically to Joe that is very cheeky
and like in a it could have been
pretentious but there's this little
there's this little trick done in
regards to Joe and what happens to Joe
at the end that feels and character and
feels now it is really cool
it's just clever like this movie is just
really smart it is smartly constructed
smartly written smartly directed smartly
acted it's just really intelligently
executed Greta Gerwig who wrote and
directed this and criminally is not up
for Best Director
the film's up for Best Picture which it
deserves it's up for Best Adapted
Screenplay which it definitely deserves
she's not up for director which is
really weird for me because if you got
to nominate her for the screenplay like
the screenplay the directing especially
in this instance that's truly hand in
hand so mmm but anyway what she is able
to do and bring to this in terms of
finding the hearts of these characters
and bringing them to life flaws and all
because you have characters like Lori
who he's a tough character for me to
watch sometimes because he's a bit of a
selfish douche at times and I wish I'd
been recognized
as much of my own past history in him as
I do but he's really well executed and
everybody's really well cast
Laura Dern as their mother is excellent
Chris Cooper's terrific Bob Odenkirk is
wonderfully affable and in the role that
that he has it's just really good I'm
not gonna go so far as to say everyone
should rush out and see it I get like
especially for my audience that probably
a minority of you haven't any kind of
interest in this subject matter but if
you think there's even an inkling that
you might get something out of this I
would honestly seek it out it's really
really good and it's touching and parts
of it are heartbreaking I did cry in
this movie but pretty pretty much for
the same reasons that that Joey wanted
to put the book in the freezer for those
of you who caught that reference but
it's just really good I'm glad I saw it
I wish I'd caught it before the end of
the year because it would have made my
top ten
what made it high on there to like four
or five knives out was a little bit
better that probably still would have
slipped in that like maybe three but
like between those two boy who knives
how you want okay well movie should have
gotten nominations all right I'm tangent
ting I'm gonna wrap it up little women
did you see it what you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff to do if you
want to help me out in terms of paying
my bills and being able to afford to see
my partner and go out to the movies um I
have a patreon that's greatly
appreciated even if you're not able to
do that like subscribe comment those do
actually help me out as well so whatever
you want to do with that with any of it
with none it with none of it cuz I'm not
gonna tell you what to do end of the day
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]